now that the somatic universe is so well
known the MCU is something people
understand people enjoy people like and
I think what people enjoy most about it
is that they're all different we try to
make all of these films stand apart hey
everybody its charlie we get a bunch of
Marvel phase 4 movie news you may have
heard about Disney shifting some movie
dates around their master schedule has
changed a little bit Tom Holland has
also been talking about more spider-man
films so I'll explain everything there's
a new round of that spider-man ps4 game
giveaway all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a
Marvel related comment on the video I
named a new winner at the end of this
the reason why Marvel just changed their
master movie schedule is because they
have 9 movies that are dated they're all
untitled Marvel films although we know
what some of them are gonna be one of
them was dated for July 31st 2020 and
that was just taken off the schedule out
right now there are only two Marvel
movies scheduled for that year but this
doesn't include all the new movies that
are gonna get when they get Deadpool the
x-men films and Fantastic Four because
you have to remember that those movies
will be released by Disney Dark Phoenix
will probably be the first Disney
release Marvel movie even though
technically it won't be Kevin Feige
Marvel it'll be Fox Marvel Disney will
just release it in theaters next summer
as a Disney film instead of 20th Century
Fox after that and New Mutants every
other Marvel movie will have come
through Kevin Feige on a creative level
so when Drew Goddard and Ryan Reynolds
wind up making their x-force movie
that'll be in conjunction with Kevin
Feige as creative input
although Drew Goddard is really awesome
and they're doing really awesome things
with the Deadpool movies I have a
feeling he'll just let them do what they
do best the rumor is - why they've
removed that Marvel movie off the
schedule in July is probably because it
was gonna be when they were releasing
guardians of the galaxy 3 because that's
on indefinite hold now there's no reason
to keep it on the schedule so they just
take it off you may have heard about
them looking for a new female director
to do James Gunn's script when we get
something official about that I'll do a
new video but for now it's just blowing
in the wind there was news recently
about Benedict Wong at a fan convention
talking about Doctor Strange - saying
that he hoped to start filming that
before the end of the year now that's
not confirmation but it is possible
that they're ready to go with that and
they fast-track it because of the hole
that's being left by Guardians 3 there's
a movie coming out in November 2020
there's just an untitled Marvel film
that's probably gonna wind up being the
Black Widow film typically what happens
is is there's a movie that they're not
totally sure whether or not it's gonna
be a huge bang out hit they'll release
it in that November date like when they
did the first Doctor Strange movie they
weren't sure how it was gonna do
Benedict Cumberbatch is really really
popular but you just don't know till you
know so they put it in November it did
fine
so they'll probably do the same thing
with the Black Widow movie usually what
Studios do when they know they have a
slam-dunk on their hands like an
Avengers movie is they'll release it in
the spring or the summer there are a
couple exceptions to that like Black
Panther is obviously making crazy money
they released that in February the first
Deadpool movie was a February movie it
made crazy money so it doesn't matter
quite as much now but still spring
summer movies tend to be the biggest
ones of the year you probably heard the
rumors about Tom Holland letting slip
that Marvel and Sony are planning on
doing a third spider-man film together
Tom Holland probably has an idea for
what's going on but plans change over
time so what'll happen is is after they
release far from home next summer then
you'll start hear them talking about
what's happening with the future of
spider-man between Marvel and Sony the
success of the venom movie will mostly
lead to more venom movies at Sony
getting bolder with those other
spin-offs like Morbius the Kraven the
hunter movie they finally officially
confirm black panther 2 with ryan
coogler so they said that the probably
won't see that till February 2021 just
because ryan coogler wants to take a
little extra time to get the script
right so that it can be a really big
movie because black panther over
performs so much that it's gonna be
really hard to beat that
but based on what Kevin Feige is saying
about how they're getting weirder and
weirder in the Marvel Universe doing
really cool things that they would have
never been brave enough to try before
that it'll wind up being something
really really cool because it's one of
the new crown jewels of the Marvel
franchise to make as many royalty puns
as possible right now there's no date
for the Eternals movie but it seems like
they already have a script for that so
they could start filming next year
that's one of the franchises that Kevin
Feige is referring to when he says that
they're gonna be trying weirder crazier
stuff that you've never seen before and
then of course there will be a fifth
Avengers film probably not till that May
six 2020 to date but the really cool
thing that just happened is as Tom
Hiddleston did a big comic-con panel I
put some of the Avengers for talk that
he did in another video but here's a
clip of him talking about Kevin Feige
'he's creative process that will give
you an idea for how crazy they're going
to get in phase four I think it's also
isn't understanding the process behind
making these films and as I think
everybody Marvel I think they had they
take huge confidence with every new leap
Kevin Feige has told me that that the
fact that people enjoyed the first
thought film gave him the confidence to
dream guardians of the galaxy into
existence he thought okay people accept
that superheroes are going to leave
earth and go into space and and then
when guardians worked it was like he
knew he could start cooking infinity war
and I think so as Marvel have grown in
in in their extraordinary and
unprecedented creative confidence I
think I felt more confident in their
processes I mean it's it's so it's so
easy to rewrite your own history
I remember being terrified making the
first Avengers film because
it wasn't a given that it was going to
work it was it was
only worked based on how hard we worked
to make it work so you hear what Tom
Hiddleston says about Kevin Feige
getting bolder and bolder with his
choices particularly infinity war and
Avengers for now think about what he's
gonna do once they get their hands on
the x-men Fantastic Four IP is gonna be
crazy the one thing that he did confirm
though is there would be more crossovers
Thor Ragnarok spider-man Homecoming
style where you see characters popping
up in other people's films even if
they're not co-headlining like Hulk was
a big main character throughout Thor
Ragnarok
but even though Iron Man was hyped up as
being a big presence in homecoming he
was really only in the film for less
than 10 minutes so you see a lot of that
stuff to where you see flashbacks or you
see like those funny Captain America
serials where they include characters
but it's only in messages or flashbacks
or other funny ways spider-man far from
home is probably an even better example
of that because of all the different
London stuff we've been seeing with him
popping up and Venice in the boat with
Nick Fury them in London with Maria Hill
happy Hogan showing up so you get a
little bit of the Marvel Universe in
everybody's movies in different forms
without necessarily them overtaking the
entire film like the plot apart from
home will still revolve around Peter
saving the day he just gets a little bit
of advice from other people and a little
bit of help when it's necessary a lot of
really weird crossovers all connected by
this through line of the Avengers films
first ten years it was Stannis in the
Infinity Gauntlet next ten years will
probably be something on a more
multiversal level but well obviously
we'll get teasers for that when we start
seeing footage for Avengers 4 so let me
know in the comments below which phase
four movie are you most hyped up for
right now daredevil season 3 is out I'll
be doing new videos for that soon leave
all your requests in the comments below
congratulations John Doe you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
my channel so I can get your details
click here to learn about Netflix
canceling iron fist and Luke Cage and
click here for my breakdown of that
Avengers 4 trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
you